Business Insider reported an interesting
little study showing that regular
drinkers are less likely to die
prematurely than people who don't drink
at all the study look at individuals
between ages 55 and 65 spanning a
20-year period and accounted for
variables ranging from socioeconomic
status to level of physical activity of
the 1824 study participants forty-one
percent of the moderate drinkers died
prematurely sixty-nine percent of the
non drinkers died prematurely that's a
lot of people and sixty percent of the
heavy drinkers died prematurely some of
the reasons that they say the drinking
could be helpful beyond you know there's
restaurant all in red wine and as I
always say Barbara Walters baines in it
um you know that it also that alcohols
also a social lubricant you have a drink
you talk to people you talk to people
and your endorphins are going you feel
better you might treat yourself a little
bit better so there's there's some
social reasons for it um non drinkers
have also been shown to scientist have
greater instances of depression which
even though alcohol is depressant I
think that's kind of interesting um so
first up we just have to say them that
excessive drinking is no good but that
basically something like a who paid for
that stuff as although Absolut Vodka
yeah who did this I mean it's been a zoo
Scheider they didn't do the study but
they reported on it made for it though
that's where you could dwell everybody
every study we do you got you know
almonds are supposed to cure cancer well
who presumably paid for that study
you're telling me the almond people or
not I would assume so I'm a skeptic and
used to drink you might die prematurely
at any time just a little bit of fear
negative language put in something I
agree with you when I see negative
language and studies and I see a little
bit of something fear like words die
prematurely which they by the way never
identify what premature like that mean
it's like natural causes like what is
that means you're dying prematurely
means you're dying before the average
person dies of natural causes ISM my New
York accent came out there I'm assuming
he says I'm for natural causes
no I was Jason moderation but you know I
had really looked this up but I did
Google the top 10 drinking countries and
Great Britain is number one and China
and Russia two and three it's
interesting in America doesn't even make
the top ten list so we tend to be living
pretty long here but I think it's uh
there's so many factors in that and I
just I think that study is skeptical at
best yeah so we've had a theme in this
episode at least of these these social
things is the next thing that's going to
happen once the weed thing is taken care
of that the next fight might be to lower
the drinking age because right now we
can send you off to fight a war overseas
and you're not allowed to have a beer I
think that's going to really depend on
law enforcement and what they think
financially is going to go into policing
that and changing things with that I
mean I don't understand why an 18 year
old who's an adult and can go off to war
can't have a beer it's ridiculous it's
silly to me the fact that when you can
have marijuana now is it 18 or 21 its
twenty moment where I wanted to go I
just seemed silly if you're an adult
you're an adult or are you not so I mean
silly to me yeah whatever what's the
time yeah what's the rationalization
there when people say you can go to war
we will literally send you a crossbow on
the rest killed personalization is when
you're younger and you're 18 you are
less likely to make good decisions so
you might sign up to go to war in
America wants that seriously they say
that you when you're 18 you might make
poor decisions you might misuse
marijuana or alcohol that's probably
true because when i was 18 i probably
didn't have all the information or
wisdom i have now I certainly didn't
yeah and when I was 18 years old or with
anyone he's 18 years old you're more
likely to make a judgment based on
something irrational so of course yeah
they don't you to drink but they don't
want to stop you from signing up to a
war that they just to go right you might
have the irrational thought that the
government would take care of after the
world everybody rushes I goes to war is
being irrational or stupid or anything
I'm not saying that at all I mean
obviously you know they're doing
something that other people aren't doing
but I'm saying it isn't the best
interest to have younger people who
might be more risk takers rather than as
you get older you get more risk-averse
most people to go off into something
that's really scary because right now I
can't even imagine when I was younger if
you would sent me into some sort of
battle I probably would have had that
that false sense if I can't dine
nothing's going to happen to me in the
future
great but as you get older you get like
Oh everything's terrifying and you know
it scared yeah me not you yeah are you
are taking more risks drunk right now I
want to live what's in their water i
delegate why i like the record we are
not being paid by fred people as far as
i know if they had done this study in
didn't come out the other way saying
that drinking does lead to premature
death do you think that would stop
anyone from drinking cuz I to me these
things I agree these studies are you
gotta figure out where they're from and
all that but also that people just sort
of do what they do and we can look at it
but they just do with a sigma against
drinking in this country we even
prohibited for about five years with
prohibition which didn't work so you
have families in Europe that start kids
drinking a glass of wine or sip of wine
when they're young and so it's not a big
don't and now in this country after
weight to your 21 so people figure out a
way to get around that so it might be
reasonable to lower and again once you
can have it it's legal then there's not
as much interest and I think that's
probably a healthy thing to do